don't move let me see it
don't move amy is here okay
ready
i love it that's super sweet because
it's terrible
[Music]
oh my god where have you been joel
amy i love you i'm gonna come find you
the day of the monster uprising
was the day i lost everyone only a small
fraction of humanity survived to move
underground i've been scanning for amy
the entire time
and now i finally found her oh hey amy
is that you
oh my god hey
how far away is amy's colony 85 miles
it's an impossible journey everything
we'll try to kill you
don't fight just run and hide
okay
you all alone me too you don't have to
talk about it
you wanna come with me
is that a samurai sword yeah yes it is
listen to your instincts out here man
what if i have terrible instincts
[Music]
you'll die super encouraging speech
you made it all this way for a girl huh
do you ever hear the term fools
no amy i miss you so much
we have lost this wolf we could still
take our world back
you're more of a survivor than i thought
oh that was awesome oh i feel like tom
cruise
you